let's talk about the health benefits of cacao
and dark chocolate now cacao is the raw bean
that's then fermented and processed into chocolate
okay but there are some serious health benefits to
both of these items in fact six billion pounds is
consumed on a yearly basis it is loaded with some
serious phytonutrients polyphenols and flavonols
which is more in quantity than blueberries or
acai berries now there's a tiny bit of caffeine
involved but you have a good amount of theobromine
which is a stimulant so of course if you're going
to consume this later in the day or before bed
that may keep you up now i consume a little bit
of chocolate on a regular basis not too much but
i always consume no sugar type chocolate i always
make sure that it's organic because they do spray
different chemicals including using glyphosate i
primarily use these two brands right here there's
other ones that you can get as well but they're
usually flavored with erythritol and monk fruit
or stevia so there's quite a variety that you
can choose from all right let's look at the
benefits of cacao and dark chocolate there's
some seriously amazing benefits for the heart
decrease blood pressure because you're getting
increased nitric oxide which actually helps the
smooth muscle of the arteries now the blood
pressure effect can also happen due to the
high levels of magnesium it's also loaded with
iron and potassium and copper and phosphorus and
zinc number two it can increase your hdl decrease
your ldl especially the oxidized ldl number three
major studies showing the decrease in risk of
heart disease okay this is the big one right here
decreasing endothelial dysfunction this is where
heart disease starts it's the inside of the layer
of the artery specifically the coronary
that starts to become damaged and then the
cholesterol comes and the calcium comes and builds
up plaquing and a clot and so these antioxidants
protect the inside layer of the artery of
course if you consume chocolate without the
sugar which is like you know sandpaper on the
arteries all right number four decreasing cortisol
and adrenaline this is why many times
people consume chocolate to reduce stress
all right number five it may decrease the risk
of certain cancers number six decreasing insulin
improves insulin resistance okay number
seven you can decrease the risk of strokes
number eight it can elevate your mood and bring
someone from a depressed state to a higher level
they don't know exactly why this is it could be
because of the increase in serotonin it could be
because of the theobromine but it can also be
from the polyphenols okay but regardless it
seems to create a cool effect number nine
it can increase your physical performance
ten it can really help the skin's circulation
probably because of this nitric oxide right here
the texture of your skin the hydration of your
skin and number eleven which is quite amazing
which relates to number three it can decrease
metabox syndrome which is a combination of
improving your blood sugars cholesterol
and blood pressure the only thing i want
to mention about cacao or chocolate is
that it does have higher amounts of oxlets
and so if you're at risk for kidney stones i would
probably recommend not consuming it hey before
you go real quick i have a course entitled how to
bulletproof your immune system it's a free course
i want you to take it and here's why here's you
here is your environment everyone is focused on
this over here avoiding your environment but
what about here what about strengthening your
immune system that's what's missing this course
will show you how to bulletproof yourself and so
you can tolerate and resist your environment
much better by strengthening your own immune
system i put a link down in the description right
down below check it out and get signed up today